[Music]
huh it is the United States of America's
birthday July 4th HH fod last year for
July 4th I got completely underwater
hammered I was scuba diving dude I
remember it I remember you were bad I
remember Billy Barbie in there singing
the national anthem then he sang the
Canadian national anthem and it was
funny and I had a sore throat like I
always do I had a sore throat and I had
to get one of the guests at the barbecue
who's a nurse to look at my throat and
call me an antibiotics and I left here's
the thing about the fourth of July it
was with the squeaked there's no more
American holiday than the fourth of July
because all we do are staples of
American culture yeah first of all we
get the flag out strong I'm yet all
glories flying everywhere
yeah I'm because make no mistake you do
not forget that you are in the friendly
confines of the United States of America
on July 4th you do not know you can even
be somebody with dementia and you're
gonna go which countryman in oh yeah
America possess reminders everywhere if
this is not for one second are you gonna
think you're in Canada no [ __ ] chance
cuz and you know what's interesting
about July 4th is it only became a
federal holiday in 1941 I did decide cuz
that was just beginning a world war ii
it was beginning of World War two I mean
the United States didn't come in oh well
yeah the United States has already come
in they'd coming in from you know Pearl
Harbor so yeah I think so it's kind of
like Juneteenth hasn't been a holiday
but it's gonna be one at one point like
4th of July became holiday yeah like
people didn't even get off for fourth of
July before 1941 it was always
celebrated it was all we celebrated with
festival you know festivities and
fireworks on stuff because I got to be
honest with you I mean we live in New
York City and we got a cut-out mayor
Mayor Bill DeBlasio and it's like I
don't know every day I've been here in
fireworks yeah I mean it's it sounded
like 4th of July's been here for a month
yeah with the civil unrest going on but
here's the deal the actual 4th of July
is coming and here's a few rules that
you need to know about 4th of July 1
gotta have Old Glory flying got up yeah
to God have Budweiser's on
all yeah you got a drink piss beer all
day long to celebrate America number
three God have hot dogs yep you gotta
eat a combination of pig ass and
sphincter in a [ __ ] tube all day long
cuz that's America number three nobody
who doesn't have an American passport is
allowed at your [ __ ] barbecue yeah
for those account Yanni did to number
three it's what it is cuz I'm a $3.00
bill it's what it is cuz me and you if
you put us together what do we got six
dollars six dollars which is enough to
buy hotdogs we form one full and we are
two Half Men we're two Half Men make no
mistake the show guy code and girl code
is coming back tomorrow for a one day
episode called quarantine code and I'm
sorry I started to do it I don't want to
do it it's gonna be real funny to see
that show come back it's almost like
it's almost like the reboot of Roseanne
where everyone just looks like their
grandparents yeah I'm just like yeah I
don't want to be doing the guy code of
girl code to hide of my boner I'm 35
years old I got a family I think it's
too old why did we bring this thing back
but how do I got to do it and I'm just
so [ __ ] tired right now and the
thought of having to do it tomorrow is
pissing me off it's like when they sick
when they brought back the same cast in
Goodfellas for one more run and a
Scorsese movie and they had to use CGI
to make you guys look decent and it's
just what it is and the truffle pigs
getting 10% unfortunately because he
[ __ ] sent the email right before I
can them John Adams said that July 2nd
he thought was the correct date to
celebrate independence cuz that's when
they really wrote the Declaration of
Independence and talked about it but
wasn't until ah I don't give a [ __ ]
about John Adams if I can't buy you at
his six-packs at the bodega
you're not my favorite Adams yeah I mean
John Adams he used to turn down July 4th
events in protest because he thought now
why do you think it was on July 2nd
because on July 2nd is when they
actually wrote the Declaration of
Independence but July 4th is when they
all signed it is that what it is
Oh July 2nd the Continental Congress
voted in favor of the Declaration of
Independence but July 4th
it wants to why is it July fourth then
does anybody know because it's a great
type of barbecue all because July 4th a
Continental Congress formally adopted
Declaration of Independence which had
been written largely by Thomas Jefferson
slave owners cancel he's cancelled and
here's another piece of advice for you
on the fourth of July if you're at a
barbecue where you see a lot of white
Air Force Ones and long white t-shirts
make no mistake you're at a black
barbecue yeah if you have the option for
a side vegetable like asparagus making a
mistake you're in a white barbecue it's
what it is and let me tell you something
if you're at a [ __ ] barbecue and they
start playing the national anthem and
everybody in that barbecue including
your [ __ ] disabled grandmother
doesn't get down on one knee
you're a [ __ ] racist you're a racist
in a communist you're a communist you
better get granny down a1 the Autotech
she breaks a hip it's for the red white
and blue yeah it's what it is July 4th
let's cancel what's canceling July 4th
cuz I mean our people can't even
celebrate July 4th because it's all
racist white men that made the holiday
so I'm celebrating Stalin's birthday on
July 4th it's canceled it's old its kids
late it's because we should just do a
thing where we just read someone and
read some money and we just go let's
cancel them let's cancel stuff let's
cancel it cancel it let's how do we
cancel
I would cancel myself let's just cancel
it cancel John Adams cancelled Nancy
Reagan cancelled yeah yeah off the TV
show cancelled yeah cuz it portrayed
aliens weirdly cancelled why do I keep
flexing your [ __ ] tits I've caught it
throughout the whole episodes because I
want to much coffee yeah why you keep
flexing your chest too much coffee
what are you doing cuz are you trying to
grow your tits yeah why are you so
conscious of you did I'm trying to
straighten out my anteater tent cuz
we've been sitting the whole tip about
four times I seen you flexing them why
are you doing that why are you a strange
bird I'm a strange
you're a [ __ ] $3.00 bail it's what it
is cuz I mean what can you [ __ ] do I
mean this is its market socialism is
taking over
[Music]